aujourd'hui nous nous régalons d'une
tomate sûr
une bonne salade
thèse ou encore du dernier produit
culinaire à la mode nous aimons
redécouvrir les produits de nos terroirs
et aussi craqué pour le dernier produit
culinaire tendance avant de vous faire
voyager dans le futur et que nous
réfléchissions ensemble à l'avenir de
l'alimentation
il est vrai que nous revenons quelques
années en arrière avez vous une idée de
ce que les roumains pouvaient manger
je suppose que comme moi vous les
imaginez allongé sur leur sofa en train
de manger des grappes de raisin bon ok
certes mais les romains raffolez d'un
plat assez atypique la viande de
flamants roses
d'ailleurs le mais le plus apprécié
était la langue du flamant rose
celle ci était servi pendant les repas
d'affaires continuons la pomme de terre
de nos jours la pomme de terre est le
second aliments le plus consommé au
monde juste après le blé il faut savoir
avant le 18e siècle
on pensait que la pomme de terre
transmettait des maladies elles étaient
donnés uniquement aux cochons et aux
prisonniers il a fallu attendre un
certain parmentier pour que la pomme de
terre se démocratise et qu'on en trouve
enfin dans toutes les assiettes la
tomate en ce qui concerne la tomate faut
savoir qu'on ne la consomme mais pas
avant le 10 études le xviiie siècle elle
était utilisée comme ornement décoration
plantes d'intérieur comme nous voyons
nous voyons de nous venons de le voir ce
que nous mangeons
est-ce que nous ne mangeons pas évolué
que mangeront nous en 2050 que nous
mangeons pas encore je suis persuadé
qu'en 2050 nous mangerons ceci ces
insectes
alors il faut déjà il faut savoir sur la
planète
il ya un tiers de la population qui
mangent des insectes tous les jours et
de façon volontaire en fait il qu'en
amérique du nord et en europe
occidentale on ne mange pas encore
d'insectes pour ma part j'ai découvert
les insectes un peu plus de dix ans
c'est à ce moment-là que j'ai créé le
site insectes comestibles point fr mon
but c'était de faire découvrir les
insectes aux gens aux européens plus
particulièrement aux français j'ai
commencé avec quelques insectes quelques
espèces et puis la société a évolué j'ai
maintenant plusieurs gammes plusieurs
produits
nous faisons des insectes pour
l'apéritif et nous faisons aussi des
insectes transformé par exemple des
pâtes à la farine d'insectes des barres
protéinées aux insectes
pourquoi je pense que les insectes sont
l'avenir de l'alimentation
pourquoi j'y crois la première des
choses c'est que les insectes sont
délicieux alors c'est sûr quand je me
suis retrouvé dans ma première fricassée
de verre de bambou en thaïlande
je pensais pas vous dire aujourd'hui que
les insectes sont délicieux jeu
ressemblait plus à quelqu'un qui voulait
amuser la galerie plutôt qu'un
aventurier du goût d'ailleurs mes
voisins de table avait remarqué le mot
regarder en rigolant et j'ai eu l'air
assez bête
une fois ce fou rire passé j'ai oublié
de vous montrer à quoi cela ressemble et
c'est mieux comme ça
une fois ce fou rire passé d'ailleurs je
remarque que j'ai le même fou rire quand
je fais des animations dégustation
d'insectes
je suis rendu compte que les insectes et
est bon avait une structure et un goût
différent de ce que l'on connaît ce fou
rire permet d'après moi de casser un
tabou culinaire qui est ancré dans le
patrimoine gustatives il faut savoir
qu'il ya qu'il y a environ 1900 espèces
d'insectes comestibles au monde
ça veut dire qu'il ya tout autant de
textures de saveurs de goûts différents
alors on me demande souvent quelle va
avoir le goût du vers de farine qu'il va
avoir le goût du grillon alors j'essaye
de prendre des coups qu'on connaît par
exemple vers de farine va avoir un goût
de noisette du grillon va avoir un goût
de pomme de terre
mais pour être tout à fait honnête avec
vous chacun sait qu'à son propre goût sa
propre textures je pense que l'on va
apprendre à découvrir le patrimoine
culinaire des insectes d'ici 2050 alors
si je vous disais qu'en plus d'être bon
être délicieux
les insectes sont bons pour votre santé
attention je vous dis pas de courir
d'autres jardins d'attraper un ver de
terre bleue manger vous risquez d'avoir
quelques soucis en revanche pour savoir
que les insectes sont riches en
protéines pour certains insectes ils
sont même plus riche en protéines que la
viande de boeuf dans certaines régions
du monde où les insectes sont plus cher
que la viande les femmes enceintes et
nourrissons ont préféré manger des
insectes plutôt que manger de la viande
je pense notamment en afrique avec les
chenilles
il faut savoir qu'on trouve des traces
comme quoi on manger des insectes bien
avant celle de la viande
de là à dire que les insectes sont
ancrées d'entre eux patrimoine
gustatives il n'y a qu'un pas il faut
aussi regarder l'adn de l'insecte il
faut savoir que l'adn de l'insecte est
très éloigné du nôtre ce qui évite les
transmissions de maladies
il y a très peu de chances en moins en
mangeant à l'insecte d'avoir une maladie
que l'insecte aurait pu nous transmettre
contrairement à ce que l'on peut
connaître avec par exemple la grippe
aviaire et la volaille enfin pour ceux
qui auraient du mal à se dire je veut
croquer goulûment dans une cheminée où
vous un criquet il faut imaginer les
produits transformés il faut imaginer
2050 et les plats tous les jours qui
arrivent
arrivons dans nos assiettes avec mon
équipe on travaille déjà depuis 2015 sur
certains produits
ce que vous voyez là c'est des pâtes à
la farine d'insectes on a aussi des bars
de protéines qui sont qui sont sortis
avec des de la farine d'insectes écraser
des algues je pense que ce genre de
produit vous aidera à manger des
insectes plus facilement à passer le cap
de la dégustation
si je vais pas si je vous ai pas encore
convaincu voici le dernier argument
pensez à vos enfants vos petits-enfants
et je suis persuadé qu'ils mangeront des
insectes en 2050
pourquoi c'est simple en 2050 nous
serons 10 milliards sur la planète avec
10 milliards de personnes ne rompt pas
assez de place pour élever du boeuf de
la volaille ou d'autres aliments
il faut savoir que les insectes
reproduit ce qu'ils consomment en
aliments pour faire simple en donnant 10
kg nourriture à un boeuf de la volaille
des insectes voici ce que l'on obtient
seulement un kilo de viande de boeuf 5
kg de volaille et 9 kilos d'insectes
j'insiste sur le fait qu'on a donné la
même quantité de nourriture au début il
faut savoir aussi que les insectes
produisent 10 à 100 fois moins de gaz à
effet de serre que la viande
traditionnels donc comme on l'a vu les
insectes sont délicieux nutritifs et ont
un faible impact environnemental
je pense qu'avec les insectes on peut
préparer un avenir sans viande
je vous remercie de m'avoir écouté